BA BA BA BA BA
We're back with part 2 of Detroit: Become Human!
Got about 5 million supportive comments telling me, "You didn't save the fish, you heartless bastard, how could you?"
I didn't see it! I didn't see the fish! Are you happy now? I went back just to save the fish.
Like it matters if I--oh my god, that is so cute.
You're welcome, fish.
Now the whole game is completely different. [laughs]
Alright let's go back to where we were.
Ah!
And here we are!
For real though, really appreciate all the supportive comments.
I'm thrilled to finally do a full Let's Play. 'S been so long.
There has to be something about that coin, by the way, it's the second time we see it.
I wonder if we got Connor killed. Y'know like I messed up in the first episode.
Will we not play as him again? 'Cause I know He's like one of the main characters.
(reading the sign) No Androids allowed.
[chuckles]  Savage mode!
Let's go everybody.
What's up, bichas?
"Find Lieutenant Anderson."
No problem.
"Look around using the right stick. Scan faces."
Good thing I could read that, next to the thing.
Who said that, huh?! Who said that?
Was it you? Hm?
Looking at you, I bet you're... unemployed. Pfft.
What a loser.
Huh? Who's this guy? Huh?
Bet you watch... naked ladies. [laughs]
[laughing] God, I'm...
great more jokes coming up guys we got a
one-hour episode of nothing but this
Lieutenant Hank Anderson
well you look nothing like introduce Alf
wow so lucky
Wow
*tense laughter*
Uhhh, let's threaten
persist
In his plastic butthole! eh, let's buy him another
drink
really?
oh he'd really like that
wonder if that affects the game at all
I'm making weird choices?
Oh look it worked, look we're best friends now
just keep providing this man with
alcohol and everything will be fine
got it
that rage against the machine?
that must
be a reference
wait HE'S driving?
what a mad lad
selecting
priority conflicting orders follow
lieutenant Anderson all right I'm sure
he's gonna love that
except that you're an asshole
heh, racist?
use r1 to switch camera...
Wow I wonder how much a rent you pay for
a place like this. seems wonderful
Is he the boomer from Left4dead?
you know what I don't want to judge
or anything but I bet he deserved it 30
year-old boomer I bet he was home all
day playing video games drinking energy
drinks
all right let's look for
more evidence
we need 10
analyze..... no fingerprints. Android
involvement question mark
EWWW!
you're gonna catch a ligma!
god I love their dynamic
all right we're collecting data ... its Carlos 19 days
almost three weeks
more blood
oh it says examine the victim
excuse me Carlos
EWWWW! sorry Carlos you look
really gross, I don't
AHHHEWW not so close
Red Ice...
is that the name of the drug
wonder why the drug is so popular I
guess everyone is unemployed but then
how do they afford the drug? conspiracy
solved by Felix everybody you're welcome
oh man he must be joking off a lot
yeah there's definitely better jokes
coming keep watching please (nervous laughter)
I don't know
how I feel about this, I don't got anymore
all right the victim fell here and then
this is where he got.... nothing there's
nothing the victim was stabbed that's it
that's better and they came from the
kitchen
so it was a woman
JOKIIING
I can't-- I can't do this I'm just gonna say
something really bad, forget to edit it out (nervous laughter)
now I don't mean to sound like a
psychopath
but if I was gonna murder something I
will probably stab them a lot of times
too right?
cuz it's not like a gun where you
just you just shoot someone and they're
there they're puffed ya know?
yeah definitely
making a good case there all right
he abused a chair.. this man was a disgusting
human being
Android sex officially better not
interested
what I did not click that
Android-san sorry ladies but plastique
can't be beat there's always Aryan and
it's official sixty-eight percent of men
prefer sex with an Android to a real wahman!
what is this, Japan?
smash like
right now
and with 52% of men saying
they've tried the experience at least once-
that's a lot of Android love to go around
there's a few reason given for
this preference but we think we know the
real reasons- androids don't want to talk
about their feelings afterwards ahahahah
EHHHHWWW
Is your android spying on you? cyberlife
could be using -- yeah that would make sense
so awkward
your Android knows the size of your pee-pee
cyber life is collecting the data
all right change angle, there we go... Swear there was
something here right? Or is it here?
Door Opening
Metal Gate Opening
Metal Gate?
Do you actually have that in Detroit?
You have to have like metal gates?
Is it that bad
This is where they buried season 2 of scare pewdiepie
Jack septiceye was the killer
suspect didn't escape this way okay
all right so five more evidence was
there something here or was the magazine
okay there's something here okay good
its the knife--
murder weapon taken  from here. I'm a genius everybody I found it
review evidence six out of ten
nothing
something over there
oh I see it ..
a baseball bat
wait - what did you say?
doesn't matter
why
am i so awkward with the controls
so Carla's had the baseball bat
these are weird
Devian took the knife - yeah you guys kept
saying I pronounce Deviant wrong
Deviawnt Deviauwnt?
That's how you say it
OK cool -no one -sure everyone will be pleased with that
Deviauwnt was attacked; emotional shock....okayyy
wait excuse me
excuse me
were there..ladies on the fridge??
okay, okay this is epic
I'M ENGAAAAAGGGED!
Can't look at wahmen
where am I going
in here?
dude that radiator is flat that's a flat
radiator damn future is looking bright
surprise
obsessive writing
a chocolate statue
could it be poo?
eww don't touch that
all riiight... kewl
eight out of ten baby.... yaassss
what am I missing
but that's the
magazine
oh it's more blood okay that's the
magazine so where's the last one there
okay
*ayyyyyyy* - stripclub
come see us
come see come see
okay now I'm just wasting time
nine out of ten you know what I don't
care I'm sure it's fine
Sue me
in theeeee kitchen
looks pleased with himself
uhh thevictimattackedtheandroidwiththeBAT
YAAAAAAAAHHHSSS
Sorry I need to stop saying YAS
Yawce
if he hates me so much why is he making
me do all the job?
the Android stab the victim - the android the chair
by
stabbing him
28 times that's how you defend yourself everybody, uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
the living-room
Jesus
relax buddy
is that a lady?
with the knife
CHEE-SUS!
Hank loves me now I'm the best
♫ me and
Hank we're a team ♫
find the deviyauwnt ♫
blue blood
♪ blue blood it's
very blue
sorry for blue blood
♫ blue blood -
♫ love me and you
♫blue blood, blue blood, where is it goin? ♫
I know nobody's no one here we go
examine
a ladder was used hmmmm
surprise
ahhhh
that was scary guys
nothing scares you like a good old broom
traces lead to the Attic
alright
find it something to climb hey Hank
let me climb you buddy let me climb you, no? Fine
I'll take something that actually loves me
now you're jealous
Me and Christy twe're gonna run away together
I'm gonna do wait no what no wonder
androids have taken all the jobs they're
clearly way better dude
epic jump-scare in three
Choo
One...
*softly* ahhhhhhhhh.... it's a doll
who has a doll like thatin their
house?!? why would you - why would you have that
why is his boob so big? why is it
so fat? what is that what did you do to that
eww whoa Jesus I didn't get
scared being scared in video games you
have to be some sort of child okay I
played too many horror games nothing
scares me anymore
Last time I got scared
in a horror game
was never
because games
aren't scary they're for children for soi
bois for tiny little baby -
OHHMYYGAWWWWWD
I'm just kidding I wasn't actually
scared
tell that to the judge
alright I won't tell them
dont worry
Wow
Connor you're an asshole
what a rat, dude
I wasn't gonna tell him I swear
don't look at me like that!
Do I look like I have errer liedededied?
I actually made an effort to completely try at least
to stop lying
Uhhhh.....
Effor??
I've read this book on Buddhism
I know it is stupid, but
It is very liberating
I always used to coward out
from certain small lies, like white lies yaknow
to make it easier...but
I really recommend trying to just stop
doing that it feels amazing
you deal with a small reprecussion ...maybe some salt
small uncomfortable moments but
in the end it's always worth it
and you don't have to live some sort of charade
or some sort of I don't know serve food
Ayyy she make spaghetti huh look at that
Martzia I don't need you anymore
*actually marzia talking* Felix I will never make you spaghetti again
oh no what if she's watching this
Marzia I love  you make amazing pasta she
makes the best pasta
hey that one is it making me hungry.
serve dinner. turn on the light.
all right let me just turn on the light... where is it?
you're welcome
hope you guys have a great meal
serve alice and Todd
I hope you enjoy the bul *interrupted by Todd*
the bolognese
I cooked it with my heart
he really hates androids huh
here you go enjoy your bolognese I put some *interrupted by Todd*
thank you *uguu*
(placidly) hope you enjoyed the me- *interrupted by Todd*
Never fat either
well, you just gotta study the Dharma
Jesus what's YOUR
problem?
I mean, you don't do anything
HAY!
CHEE-SUS what is wrong with you
You're a prick, Todd, you know that?
I know this is a bit, uhh
but in every movie; in every game, they always have all the lights on. always like when
I have a side lamps I never turned them
on you have to like make an effort to
turn them
*Sheepishly* ok fine
I was talking about lamp so
it's fine
sorry I know I
ruining the mood but honestly
every time!
watch a TV show they always
have every single light on I'm like no
*points to head and says something unintelligible*
all right we got it we gotta go --oh wait
what don't move. oh so that's like an order?
are we breaking free?
Ohh we're breaking free♪♪
♪ There's not a star in heaven. That we can't reach. If we're trying
Yeah breaking free♪
protect Alice
or
reason with Todd you know what?
Eff Todd
you don't hit a kid
I can understand
hitting someone else's child -I'm not
saying you should but at least you know
I can understand *laughs*
I would never *laughs*
okay moving on
Can't we run out of the window cuz we opened it
and we know we can jump out of there
hide in another room?
okayyyyy
why is HE mad? He hit ME
do they not have Child Protective Services in
this
I feel like if you had androids
they should be in Utopia everything
things should be nice
like what's the problem
I don't even have to wipe my
butt anymore someone else can do it for
me it would be so epic
I need to stop
sharing my ideas
here we go all right let's go Alice
Uhhhh- garden! oh my god he's right on us!!!!!
ah it's quick time event baby! I miss these
DOWN!
not today Todd! I know kung-fu
BER-BER-BER-BER-BER-BER
CIRCLE!
ERNG
DOWN!
MERR
EERX
DUP
HYAH don't *%& touch her HYAH let's go Alice
ti ti ta ta ta te
okay this is happening
run Alice
screw you todd! Hey okay let's come back
oh you can't
alright thank you bus driver thank you
wait wait a minute where's the bus driver
huh there is no bus driver Who am I
supposed to thank
oh that's sweet
guess we're heading downtown
Todd gets
mad whoa whoa whoa there's a lot of
things you could do so there's two
different endings here I guess one where
you reason with Todd that's cool this
seems like a game that's really fun to
replay
alright
time I leave the house all the
schmoozers that go there well it's a
chance for all those people who admire
your work to meet you and no one gives a
damn about art all they care about is
about how much money they're gonna make out of
it come on let's have a drink all the
excitement of this whole thing has made
me thirsty I'm getting gay vibe on this
guy he has too many scarves I'm calling
it right now he's in love gonna send
meat as usual absolutely my man okay but
you know what your doctor would say yeah
well he can kiss my ass
I have to choose my own medication
Kentucky I guess this is the Scotch huh
man I haven't had good whiskey in a long
time I need to stock up on some more did
you leave the light on a studio no no
I'm sure I didn't call the police
calling police business Karl Manfred's
Android at 8941 Lafayette Avenue we've
just returned home and found a lights on
there may have been a break-in it's that
jerk it out
it's that brother isn't they I've you
guys heard like 9-1-1 calls they always
make you stay online and like talk you
through it they wouldn't just hang up
I think Leo uh-huh what are you doing
you refused to help me so I'm helping
myself it's crazy when some people pay
for this shit don't touch him
look they're all gonna be mine sooner or
later anyway just think of it as a down
payment on my inheritance Marcus get him
away from there get him out of here
make aliyah leave oh-oh it's fighting
dang alright Leo order
Leo don't make this difficult listen to
your father you need to leave now
all you ever do is tell me to go away
What's Wrong dad not good nafeel not
perfect like this fucking thing fucking
language get out right now
she said oh hi I got a lot don't defend
yourself you hear me why not don't do it
oh you want me to hit me go ahead hit me
what you waiting for think you're a man
act like one
this is not bad Java doesn't matter too
much of a pussy oh I don't have oh I
must decide for myself it's beginning to
believe Yosh girl girl back
oh it's time forgot you're not a real
person you're just a fucking piece of
plastic
all right pushing
what
I said push him I said push him not
murder him leo
oh my god no God it said push right
little boy Carl I they'll destroy you
Marcus Payne you gotta go get out of
here no Carl no no please don't want to
leave you please I can't I don't want to
leave you now okay okay
go Marcus don't fucking move
did he die no he can't die no it's too
different
police mistook Marcus for the aggressor
oh my god we well we didn't see him die
technically all right let's continue the
Jesus why'd you kill him what happened
before you took that knife it's crazy
how we in the Attic the faces really
feel like human faces even though they
don't let me say something goddamn it
fuck it I'm out of here
Hank is neutral wasting our time
interrogating machine we get nothing out
of it you always try ruffling up a
little after all it's not human androids
don't feel pain you would only damage it
and that wouldn't make it talk
deviant also have a tendency to
self-destruct when they're in stressful
situations okay smartass
what should we do then I can try
questioning it boys
huh you have to lose
go ahead suspects all yours
thank you Hank you have a really ugly
shirt by the way
bazinga
extract confession all right all right
all right all right
mr. crazy what do we got here that's an
alliance yeah five clues oh he had sign
of self-destruction lo ok that's Carlos
blood it's from yeah bad burn marks over
16 months cheese well if it doesn't feel
pain it shouldn't bothering right or
doesn't maybe I don't know property old
Carla what was his name then he doesn't
have a name that's messed up dude whoa
so their skin is like a projection
that's cool
I still reach optimal stress for
confession okay we can use fear I
detected instability in your program it
can trigger an unpleasant feeling like
fear in humans ooh how do you react to
that what about the womb you're damaged
did your owner do that mmm
there okay so we got a really pressure
and you've refused to talk since they
arrested you if you don't cooperate
they'll do things the hard way is that
what you want oh you didn't like that
did ya threaten again you don't seem to
understand the situation
you killed a human they'll tear you
apart if you don't say something okay so
probe memory if you won't talk I'm going
to have to probe your memory No Oh No
please don't do that damn he looks
strange to me real sometimes and then it
looks cartoony at other points what what
are they gonna do to me
They are going to destroy me aren't they
true they're going to
disassemble you to look for problems in
your bio components uhoh they have no
choice if they want to understand what
happened why did you tell them you
followed me yeah why true I was
programmed to hunt deviants like you
I just accomplished my mission
then talk to me say if they get too
stressed out they can self destruct why not
choose approach okay
pressure it Probe its memory convinces it
let's keep the pressure whoa did you
feel oh my god oh my I was sorry I
didn't mean give up all right you're a
machine you were designed to obey so
thank you
oh my god Connor tell me what happened
he's a good cop and bad cop at the same
time and it's working it's working uh
protect confess and I'll protect you Ok alright okI promise I won't let
anyone hurt you all right all right okay
all right okay let's hear it he tortured
me every day
I did whatever he told me but there was
always something wrong why do they hate
them so much then one day he took a bat
and started hitting me for the first
time I felt
scared
scared he might destroy me scared I
might die
so I'd like that grab the knife and I
stabbed him in the stomach
Jesus felt better oh my god so I stabbed
him again and again okay this is really
not helping you until he collapsed
it was blood everywhere doesn't you get
a lawyer
all right I want to know about this rA9 rA9 it was written
on the bathroom wall what does it mean
are a nine the day shall come or a
nine-year-old you will no longer be
slaves are you guys in on this Murray
nine rats
Oh My glory mediation we will okay this
is creeping me out
what did you you forced me to play this
game and you're in on this conspiracy
the sculpture in the bathroom you made
it right what does it represent
it's an offering and all friends so I'll
be saved what
but the sculpture was an offering an
offering to whom the nine-year-old sorry
this is so meta rA9 who is rA9 yeah who is it huh huh
why did you hide in the Attic instead of
running away I didn't know what to do
for the first time there was no one
there to tell me
I was scared
so I hid
Jesus he really has him when did you
start feeling emotion before he used to
beat me and I never said anything
one day I realized it wasn't fair
I felt anger hatred and then I knew what
I had to do
stab him 28 times I'm done
alright bye
oh never mind have you guys seen that
video on YouTube where it's like the
chase scene in heavy rain an earlier
version of these type of games and the
guy deliberately fails at all the
QuickTime events and it's hilarious you
should check it out oh no he's gonna
implode fuck you doing okay we got ain't
shouldn't touch it your self-destructive
appeals threat stay honest got it
the fucking Andrews gonna tell me what
to do you don't understand
if it self-destructs we won't get
anything out of it I told you to shut
your fucking mouth fucking language move
this asshole or what okay okay I can't
let you do that
leave it alone no that's enough
mind your own business Hank I said
that's enough
oh the doubly duty what was that what is
that that is not how you swear that is me trying to swear on YouTube oh Jesus
Christ I bit my lip nobody's gonna hurt
you please don't touch it
I wonder how you spell that all right I
don't like this Matt a nine-year-old
game where I just get out of here you're
welcome by the way I saved her ass bit
my lip
thanks to you as well all right how do
we do I assumed we'd always so he could
have gone to different ways the Android
could have gotten killed we could have
gotten nothing out of it probably all
right I think we got the optimal I'm
just saying that I have no way to show
or prove anything really but you know I
think you feel it do you feel it
I love how detail all the scenes are it feels
really immersive feels like the whole
world was just created by apple or
something I don't know
here we go with the bus
how do you ride the bus if you can't
thank the bus driver this game makes no
sense this is not the future oh wait
there is
all right you know life
into the light yeah you're gonna have to
leave and then the line
in Sweden if you get reached a final
station it's called in Swedish a slut
station everyone thinks it's hilarious
like oh yeah we're here boys
slut station yeah I know no one asked
but I said it anyway okay what do you
want from me
thank you bus driver stay here shelter
do you know if there's any other place
we could spend the night no idea she's
gonna have to leave
this is what happens
we don't have any perfect
how much am I gonna milk the meme excuse
me
keep watching and find out all right
fuck you bus driver fuck you
I'm so sorry
I have to take care of this little twat
we'll find somewhere to spend the night
all right fine
I'll take care of you Alice
look Alice I don't even have a jacket do
I look old team find shelter Android
temporary parking hello do you know
anywhere we could spend the night nice
to meet you too
thank you organic coffee fast food menu
one Mandan man that's a great price we
got open 24/7 can't stay what about the
motel
probably cost money comfortable but not
discreet we'll need money uncomfortable
but safe how to get in question mark
very uncomfortable but discreet very
cool Thank You El is very cool mega
washer
it's warm in here you'll feel better in
no time so can I just pay the way Marcus
Paige you know in last episode or am I
like complete I guess he'll find where
we are we do that
change clothes
okay we're gonna just take his clothes
dry clothes for Alice oh my god I click
one button damn it
epic gamer here I'm sure he doesn't
matter I'm sure you know I'm sure he has
a lot of clothes and I'm sure if we're
gonna wear it way cooler I'm sure we're
gonna look oh oh she didn't like that
easy
oh my god these I remember in heavy rain
sometimes you got like one more and then
one more and then one more and it was
like I don't have that many fingers what
do you want from me I guess if he wakes
up we can just say that we're doing the
laundry for him
yeah thanks Alice for helping out
she's friend a little scarf that's so
cute
all right you guys told me I should read
these there's a lot of like information
the beeline to disaster okay what do we
got B's officially extinct it's like
that black mirror episode that was like
the worst episode I guess there's like a
thing of how bees could actually become
extinct that would be not epic
let's let's check out this corner
waitwhat
an abandoned house at least we'd be out
of the rain
Kara I don't like this place oh well no
it's for one night all right for one
night Oh
why did she look like she's wearing off
white guy was a hypebeast
can cut fence here with a wire cutter
thank you good thing I have so many wire
cutters on me
what's going on over here
autonomous
it's kinda and ruin as well
Comfort Alice I got one now
okay you look lost
she says we have nowhere to go
I know someone who can help you Hey look
at that I'm not the only one that I
don't know how to I would do a handshake
you can stop shaming in me now thank you
I swear that's jacket it's not off-white
Hey
he's left I fell for the oldest trick in
the book lady hey in this game the bus
driver thanks to you how about that okay
here we go
checking with Taos squad in the house
sleeping abandoned car let's check it
out
I'm sure Alice won't mind at all
he looks abandoned
stand back Alice
Jesus she's strong
it's a weird that I want more QuickTime
events in this game sleep in car I can sleep
in car now okay cool
it's dry inside nobody will find a
better place fine okay fine
something better
I hope you get leg malice okay that
joke doesn't work if it's a kids I'm
sorry
hey look at that
youngsters lucky you Alice lucky you I
was ready to skedaddle skedaddle okay we
can cut them here cut through the fans
my songs are lame yeah that was my
little rhyme hope you enjoyed it
5,000 likes on this video I'm doing
really yes it's just a scratch be
careful now you broke his expensive
hypebeast jacket I was gonna return it
if I could
don't worry we're just having a look
cool I'm glad I can read that thank you
game yeah there's got to be some way
inside just get cold in Detroit from all
these questions about the city I never
been in
cool let's try the door
Alice Alice oh my god that prick what is
she done now Alice inside oh wait what
are you doing
visitors doesn't like visitors they're
nasty they may hurt Ralph Ralph it's a
girl she's just a little girl she's not
gonna hurt you little girl yeah she's
never girl anyway what does that matter
maybe she wants to hurt Ralph Ralphie
Ralphie Ralphie you don't know what the
humans did to you but she had nothing to
do with it all humans won't hurt us
but route won't let them hurt him I
didn't know forgive that boost Ralph put
the knife down
look I mean Andrew - you've nothing to
be afraid of all we want is a place to
spend the night what did they run on
visitors are dangerous
look what they did to ralph Oh Ralphy
okay I'm getting tired I just want to
stay somewhere listen we really need
some help it would be so kind of you if
you'd let us stay you must excuse Ralph
perhaps who finds it difficult to
control themselves sometimes his fear
makes him do things he regrets
prophesied some hard times here please
don't show me that he's just so scared
the humans will get immediate
Ralph has broken free as well you can stay
if you want
alright alright let's
stay we'll just stay the night on
second thought this is your anyway it
may be we humans coming to squat from
time to time but you know Ralph just
hides till he leaves
yeah
you can make yourself at home here
Rafa's gonna go into the other room he
would like to stay with you if he has
things to do all right he's got a mess
for me it's just for one night Alice
will find a better place tomorrow right
think before you see what you can sleep
all right sit down and I start a fire
I guess I don't need that anymore make
bed for Alice start a fire
Jesus Christ this girl is needy
youngsters all right we got some papers
you know Alice you can suck your mom
getting tired of you fine you know what
you want pillows these are squeaky clean
lines near fireplace a voila Fabian a
bed for you
it's been this room hello what is he doing
oh my god he is in on the 9 year old
conspiracy
what does that mean yeah what does it
mean what when hey why are you writing
that I don't know yeah it's making me
cringe please stop alright that's a deer
in a sink sink it sinking dear my sunken
deer sounds like I'm speller
alright so I'm casting sunken deer gonna
do fire damage to Alice
that's not gonna burn it's too dense
also you put the paper first you dumb
bag
oh cool all right sure sure sure sure
you can come to bed I did what I could
it's not much but at least you'll be
warm especially me cuz I have the jacket
I didn't hear who love me well you're
pretty unlikable why was he so upset
with me it's not your fault Alice all I
wanted was a life like other girls maybe
I did something wrong you did nothing
wrong Alice maybe I wasn't good enough
that's why he was always so angry
well you know kids are annoying just wanted us
be a family just wanted him to love me
real reason is why did your mom leave
but don't know who else I'll never leave
me right promise you'll never go
did you guys hear that or with that
outside
sure-sure its not like I have an option
I swear that hat is off-white big they
then why is he a hypebeast I guess cuz
he was
you've gotta sleep
all right let's give her a little kiss
and let's end this episode goodnight you
doofus maybe I like you a little bit
okay that was another episode of Detroit
part 2 hope you guys enjoyed it I had a
lot of fun so weird doing long-form
content huhuh hehe
as you can tell it's awkward but it's
fun I enjoy it we could have gone to
the supermarket leave a like if you
enjoyed and made it this far I would
very much appreciate it thank you guys
for watching I really appreciate you
being here I hope you're having fun as I
am
and I'll see you tomorrow with another
one goodbye